I had a friend in Afghanistan when
Taliban kicked America out and he told
me
the Americans were telling were telling
the girls they could go to school so
they built all these girls schools and
they split the afghanistani Defense
Forces there and they get funded the
Afghanistan forces to to protect these
schools you had American satellites you
had night vision goggles Taliban were
afraid to attack America leaves now you
have Afghani Defense Forces they're
basically blind they don't have
satellites anymore that don't have uh
night vision whatever so now it's a real
war the men are standing next to this
girl's school the Taliban are coming
you're some dude you're standing there
you're looking at this girl's school
going
[Music]
[ __ ] if girls go to school bounce and
you just and you didn't fight so that's
why they all gave up and Taliban took
over so quickly and when I said this the
girls like yeah they should have fought
for us feminism to why don't the women
fight can you oh wait the women can't
defend their own [ __ ] idea you need
men to defend feminism so that's why the
whole thing is stupid so the second men
don't defend it it does it just fails
it's a [ __ ] ideology it's garbage